شرطه مكافحه الارهاب في بريطانيا تحقق في
تفاصيل طرد ملوث باليورانيوم تم اكتشافه
في مطاره هيثرو بعد عثور سلطات المطار على
كميه صغيره من اليورانيوم في 29 من ديسمبر
الماضي خلال تفتيش الروتيني في الجمارك
ليتبين ان المواد المكتشفه من ضمن شحنه
قادمه من باكستان وعبر دوله ثالثه وتقول
تقارير صحفيه انها كانت متوجهه الى
ايرانيين في بريطانيا دون معرفه اهدافها
النهائيه
حول النشاط الايراني هنا في بريطانيا جاء
اخرها بعد الكشف عن شحنه من اليورانيوم في
المبنى الرابع هنا من خلفي في مطاره ورغم
قله كميه المواد المضبوطه الا ان مجرد
الكشف عنها يعني ان تهديد الايرانيه ماذا
لقائنا
وتثير الشحنه المضبوطه تساؤلات حول
الاسباب التي قد تدفع ايرانيين الى السعي
وراء الحصول على مواد كهذه في بريطانيا
وتكمل المخاوف في امكانيه استخدام كميات
قليله من اليورانيوم في صنع ما يعرف
بالقنبله القذره هدفها بالعاده استهدافه
الافراد بغبار المشع او تدمير منطقه
جغرافيه صغيره
رغم تاكيد الشرطه البريطانيه بعدم وجود
تهديد على حياه الناس حاليا الا ان
المعلومات هذه تاتي بعد اسابيع من كشف
السلطات البريطانيه عن تهديد الايرانيه
مباشره لافراد وصحفيين ايرانيين معارضين
مقيمين في بريطانيا
تساؤلات حول اين وكيف ولماذا وصلت هذه
المواد الى هنا ولمن ومع المعلومات التي
تشير الى توجهها لايرانيين مقيمين في
بريطانيا يبقى الترقب قائما حول كيف
ستتعامل بريطانيا مع هذه التهديدات التي
باتت متكرره من لندن عروب عبد الحق
العربيه